si vous tendez l'oreille vous entendrez
le passé murmures et
nous venons voir albus dumbledore
il se trouve que c'est mon frère
le monde que nous connaissons s'effondre
grindelwald le des cimes avec peine
si nous voulons le fakhr vous devrez me
faire confiance
[Musique]
c'est l'équipe qui va détruire le
sorcier le plus dangereux que ce siècle
et connu
un mage iso logist sont indispensables
assistante
un sorcier descendant d'une famille très
ancienne une enseignante
à moldus dumbledore m'a donné quelque
chose pour toi jacob
non tu te moques de moi là toutes les
chances sont de notre côté
[Musique]
en route pour sauver le monde
les apparences sont trompeuses
[Musique]
puis vote mais délicatement je pilote
exactement comme toi
[Musique]
notre guerre contre les moldus
c'est quoi cet endroit la salle qu'on a
demandé
[Musique]
exact trois points pour peuvent souffler
[Applaudissements]
est ce que j'ai
trop dangereux c'est très puissant qui
se tombent dans de mauvaises mains
panique garantie ou est-ce que vous la
vige
j'ai eu pour noël
[Musique]